have you ever noticed this little icon
on your browser you can customize it in
HTML for every page of your website this
is what we call a Fab icon it's
displayed on the browser Tab and on the
bookmarks that you add to your browser
A5 icon is a small image so for this
example we will use a 32 by 32 pixels
image by default this is what you will
see if you open an HTML file in Google
Chrome so let's change that in hand we
add a link element with rail icon Type
image slash PNG or the type of image
that you're working with
and the path to the image file
we save the file
and here we have it our Fab icon is
right there on the tab before the title